bernie didn't have to acquiesce
and bernie could have made it clear that
if you treat me that way you know one of
the moments in the republican stage
which was very interesting if you
remember
they said to trump early in the process
on the stage do you promise
that if you
do not win the nomination that you will
support the republican candidate do you
remember his answer his answer was it
depends on how you guys treat me
you look back at that and think that's
exactly what the answer should be so if
i was someone doing that that would be
my answer it depends on how you guys
treat me
political parties are not even mentioned
in the constitution george washington
warned us against them in his farewell
address john adams said that they
represented the greatest threat to
democracy this idea that they get to be
the gatekeepers they are when in court
the democratic party
argued that they don't owe it to people
to let the person who got the most votes
win we have to call the
system on what it is and let's remember
the duopoly is actually a monopoly you
know we talk like how divided we are
they are not all that divided because
the bottom line is the
military-industrial complex will get
what they want on that we are not
divided uh oil companies more than not
more than not will continue to do what
they want to do on that we are not
divided big pharmaceutical companies
will continue to obstruct any chance of
universal health care on that we are not
divided
they divide us so that we don't
recognize how undivided they are in some
very essential ways
[Music]
this week on forward marianne williamson
joins us to talk the future of the
country the democratic party politics
marianne williamson one of my favorite
people from the presidential trail in
2020
and now it is my pleasure privilege and
honor to welcome to the podcast my good
friend philosopher
author
political leader and
fellow 2020 presidential candidate
marianne williamson marianne welcome
thank you it's my privilege and honor to
be here thank you andrew are you kidding
no actually making an appearance here i
mean it means a lot to me so thank you
so the main question on everyone's mind
is what the heck are we gonna do like
what when i say we
uh what you'd refer to as conscious
humans
[Laughter]
what's like of the plan for conscious
humans
and you and i haven't sat down since
really over the last i guess it's been
over a year since we even had a podcast
conversation so one what the heck are we
gonna do and number two what have you
been doing so let's start with number
one
americans are very good with a to-do
list we like to be told this is what we
need to do and then we're very good at
doing it you can look at world war ii um
the nazis the uh
japanese imperialistic army were like
operable tumors and what we needed to do
was surgically remove them everybody
knew what we needed to do and that
generation brilliantly did it
this is more like cancer that is already
metastasized
invasive surgery doesn't necessarily
make things better in some ways makes it
worse the cancer is wrapped around some
healthy organs so you have to be careful
not to
hurt the healthy organ while you're
trying to get the bad stuff so we are
being challenged to a level of
deep analysis
that i think we are are as capable of as
individuals as anyone else
but which collectively is not what we're
known for
and so
we're all in this moment of realizing
that we're going to have to do some deep
thinking and deep analysis and deep
looking in the mirror and deep reckoning
a willingness to think outside the box
before we're going to have any serious
knowledge of number one what to do and
number two
are the people who are capable of doing
it and that's where i think we are we
all know what we need to do the status
quo will not
disrupt itself we need to turn around a
very large ship
and that ship has been
in the water for 40 years republicans
started it no democratic president
stopped it it's a massive transfer of
wealth
and uh and other resources of power into
the hands of very few americans to the
point where corporations rule the world
to the point where corporate aristocracy
has pretty much a chokehold on congress
and apparently the white house as well
it's a system of legalized bribery blah
blah blah we all kind of get that now
the issue is how do we turn that ship
around
the question which you and i have talked
about extensively and which you've
talked about publicly extensively based
on what you're doing now
do you try to transform things within
the democratic party
do you go in something like what you're
doing with the forward party
you and i know from our own experience
the world saw what they did to bernie
we know you and i know viscerally how
locked up they have it how vicious they
are how
much the establishment elite within the
democratic party the corporatist elite
um has no intention
of letting anyone who's not already
in their club and you're not in it like
george carlin would say they don't want
anyone not already in their club who's
not already articulating their
pre-ordained agenda
and
they what is that first they they ignore
you then they mock you you know then
they fight you well theoretically then
you win but then on the other hand you
have the third party
concern a lot of people are just so
predisposed
to thinking of
the very phrase third party
peripheral
you're only trying to influence the
conversation for me that's difficult
andrew because
we need to do more than influence these
people we need to replace these people
you know we need to do more than
influence the conversation it's too late
to just influence the conversation and
for that matter the conversation is
already where it needs to be the
american people get it the majority of
the american people want medicare for
all the majority of the american people
want to transf uh uh want to
uh eradicate the college loan debt the
majority of the american people want a
raise in the minimum wage the problem is
not the conversation the problem is the
way the two-party corporate dominated
duopoly obstructs democracy itself oh
yeah i said not that long ago is i
thought the problem used to be that
people didn't understand universal basic
income for example they get it but now i
i believe the problem is that our
government does not actually respond to
us absolutely
yeah that's it that's a reasonable
summary of the problem that is a
reasonable summary of the problem and i
think the american people have been
casting about for some kind of change
for
the better part of the last couple
decades really
and if you rewind to the presidentials
and the presidential election we dig
into this has a unique place in the
people's hunger for change because it
turns out that
you're more likely to see something
new in the presidential than you are uh
in local races and in many cases because
the local races are easier to suppress
presidential you and i just sort of
burst on the scene in 08 barack obama's
victory was definitely a change vote and
then in 2016 i thought that bernie's
nearly successful run against hillary
was a change
campaign i think he was the man for the
moment and i recently tweeted something
where you know i thought that dnc
um was biased towards hillary and you
know people have their own opinions
about that i thought that was fairly
objective and established but whatever
um i think even trump's victory in 16
could be interpreted as a vote for
change
and then interestingly enough i feel
like joe biden's
victory in in 2020 was also a change
vote because it was like a change from
trump
railing around
so you have the american people trying
to
grab hold of something um and then
that's getting framed in a particular
way by the media by separating us into
these two ideological camps uh and i i
do remember
so many uh people supporting bernie at
every point in the the political
spectrum and it's like oh why is it
these conservatives are supporting the
quote unquote socialist and so because
they can sense that he's genuine and
unbought and wants to make changes for
the american people and that's what a
lot of americans have wanted really
um it's only when the media says like no
no you can't vote for that person
because they're on the other side would
you agree with that generally yeah
absolutely and i think it bears
analysis how all of that went down and i
think it goes all the way back to 2000.
um the american people did vote for al
gore actually not that that was at that
time so much of a change actually george
bush represented the change but it
changed in completely opposite
right-wing direction um you're right
that obama was a vote for change but
once he got in office there was a bait
and switch there's been a lot of
frustration in the quest for change
i i think we need to be a little more
blunt a little more clear uh
not more cynical but uh more realistic
with ourselves he was given a profound
mandate for change and once he got into
the white house he became pretty much of
a corporate guy
and uh you're right when hillary clinton
said let's continue the
with the successes we've had the last
eight years with obama millions of
people said the last eight years lady
what success i'm drowning here and i
think you're right for many people who
voted for trump it was a
desire for change he turned out to be
beyond false prophet if anybody
fortified the corporatist agenda he did
yeah and then bernie so i agree with
what you said in your tweet and i
responded as such and i think that the
suppression of the bernie campaign which
is factual by the way there's no opinion
here um during the um
2016 and then again in many ways uh in
the 20 shows where
the hold that the elite corporatist
democrats have had
on the democratic party and on the
democratic process within it you know
i mean that's that that's who they are
uh it's this political media industrial
complex uh they are headquartered in
both major parties
um if you read matt tayeby's book hate
inc
you know i was saying on fox the other
day fox does it cnn msnbc does it they
say look over there if you're if you're
conservative look at the liberals and
the progressives they're your enemy if
you're a progressive or a liberal look
at the conservatives they're your enemy
because now the none of them want you to
look at who's really suppressing this
thing which is the major corporate
aristocracy which is headquartered in
both major parties
so
what do we do once again i think
you know one of my favorite books is
rilka's letters to a young poet and in
that book he says when you don't know
the answer to a question when you don't
know the answer yet
live with the question
and i think
obviously you were led to form the
forward party the very fact that you
have formed it is now factoring in i
know from me and many people i know
into the inquiry
because we've seen what happens to
people
who try to bore from within
um
in the democratic party
it's um
each of us is just going to have to
follow our own
hearts on this but i think this will be
a year this has to be the year
when
a lot of us get clearer about what role
we can best play
now the the democratic party there's
certainly a very significant
uh element of the party that
uh is in cahoots with various companies
very resistant to change very dubious of
someone who seems populist coming up
on their side
that was the point of my tweet which is
hey the democratic party seems
anti-democratic sometimes where it's
like the people are behind this bird
it's like no no no nothing you see here
you're not actually for this person
right because they can't self-fund and
all that the democratic party
has become the party of the
establishment in its own way
and the republican party is has taken on
this anti-institutionalist fervor which
i disagree with and trump i think's a
terrible uh leader and and would be an
awful it would be even worse for
president the second time yeah
if he were to come away and that's you
know a very strong statement and the
democratic party seems like it's
fighting reform efforts on one side of
itself really like there there is what
people label as the progressive wing i
try not to think of things ideologically
i agree with the majority of the goals
that you cited and that the majority of
people want them uh that's just poll
after politics that's just polls it's
numbers you know and i know too if you
talk to a conservative republican in the
midwest and you say hey you want to
stick to the drug companies i'll be like
yeah get out there being like oh you
know i love the drug companies so the
trick in my view is to try to change the
framing from left versus right which you
have said this is not the right framing
no um the right framing is the people
versus yeah it's the powerful versus the
powerless the left-right polarity is
just a cartoon version
of the political divide in this country
that was created by the real oppressors
to keep people looking at each other
rather than you know once again don't
look up right
[Music]
so let's say i totally agree with you
that the left-right thing is being
pushed on to the people as a way to
divide us and distract us right your
fellow citizen is not your enemy right
they just want you to think your fellow
citizen is your enemy yes polarization
now is rising and rising on both sides
where 42 percent of both them democrats
and republicans think the other side is
uh evil morally bankrupt uh you know
threat to the country that sort of thing
and so one reason i started the forward
party is because i think that this
polarization is going to lead us to
violence
uh unrest uh over time
um and that if you could frame it as
uh
the people versus the establishment or
something along those lines you could
bring people together
the forward party
is trying to send the message you just
articulated which is that other
americans are not your enemy
unfortunately right now you have
billions of dollars in media and um
other incentives trying to to pit us
against each other
so i have an approach that i'm enjoying
which is say look you have these two
camps that are
so somewhat artificial and like you know
the average person who's not super
engaged actually is you know like and i
i'm proud to say that i reached some
people who weren't politically activated
um previously
that if you find someone who's
non-ideological then a lot of common
sense
is very very
widespread like the common sense
actually diminishes the more politically
activated you get uh in
many of the conversations i've had um
but if you want to try and change this
dynamic you need to have a third party
um and then you would want a different
dynamic in the media because right now
you have the democratic aligned media
and the republican media so you would
need independent voices to come up that
represent something distinct from either
so that's the project i'm embarking on
the alternate version of this for
someone
who has some of the same goals
that you articulated would be to try and
transform the democratic party and the
chief way people see that quote-unquote
transform the democratic party would be
to run for a president
let's say in a democratic nomination
process the way you and i both did just
in this last cycle yes we do now there
are a couple of problems with that um
one being that the democratic party is
going to be very unfriendly to
candidates who
are trying to transform much of anything
and i'm going to say that's
approximately 100 times more true in
this upcoming cycle i agree because we
were inconvenient last time and they're
not even they don't even want us on the
first debate stage this time i'm not
even sure there will be a debate stage
that's an interesting way to look at it
as well right so so there was an article
that came out that you were quoted in
that asked whether someone was going to
primary joe biden
and you said categorically as someone
will because the people
want that
and
i believe that if someone did primary
joe biden there's a certain level of
support that they would get pretty
quickly because there are any number of
people that want bigger set of changes
than they're getting or joe was never
the candidate or you know what have you
i also think that the deck is going to
be stacked against anyone who decides to
challenge joe and that even the people
who are considered progressives who are
let's say in congress right now that
they are not going to
undertake this uh because the pressure
will be too great
and so
as someone who is on record saying hey i
totally think someone's going to
challenge joe first
who do you think might undertake this
challenge
uh and then second
um what do you think about the fact that
i'm sure that deck is going to be
stacked against that person or a set of
people it could be more than one one
person
well first of all we don't know for sure
whether the president will run again
that's number one
a lot of the people that you say will
not step forward if he does run again
might make a different decision if he's
not running again oh if he's not running
everyone comes out i think right now
they're making clear that their two main
choices they meaning the elite
establishment within the democratic
party they are clearly in love with pete
and amy
right
my analysis of how the elite democrats
would act towards a real progressive
running is exactly as yours but i've
heard a lot of people talk about how
bernie didn't have to acquiesce
and bernie could have made it clear that
if you treat me that way you know one of
the moments in the republican stage
which was very interesting if you
remember they said to trump early in the
process on the stage do you promise that
if you
do not win the nomination that you will
support the republican candidate do you
remember his answer his answer was it
depends on how you guys treat me
you look back at that and think that's
exactly what the answer should be so if
i was someone doing that that would be
my answer it depends on how you guys
treat me
political parties are not even mentioned
in the constitution george washington
warned us against them in his farewell
address john adams said that they
represented the greatest threat to
democracy this idea that they get to be
the gatekeepers they are when in court
the democratic party
argued that they don't owe it to people
to let the person who got the most votes
win we have to call the duopolistic
system on what it is and let's remember
the duopoly is actually a monopoly you
know we talk like how divided we are
they are not all that divided because
the bottom line is the
military-industrial complex will get
what they want on that we are not
divided
oil companies more than not
more than not will continue to do what
they want to do on that we are not
divided big pharmaceutical companies
will continue to obstruct any chance of
universal health care on that we are not
divided they divide us so that we don't
recognize how undivided they are in some
very essential ways if you accept this
is the set of issues and then you say
option one
run as uh progressive in the democratic
primary transform the party and don't
pretend that the democratic party is any
different than it is that you make part
of your campaign to point out that the
democratic party as bernie sanders has
been saying has strayed from its
traditional role of of true champion of
the working people of the united states
if it continues to be this basically
corporatist
uh machinery it will not
have a chance to beat donald trump have
you seen some of the
commentary
uh that bernie should have started a
third party i guess people are
successful yes that's what people are
saying people are saying he shouldn't
have stopped that when they when they
suppressed him both times he said i'm
keeping on walking because i'm running
for president and i'm not going to be
stopped i'm supported by the american
people this isn't about whether or not
the democratic party is giving me
permission and he's not even a democrat
technically why should he allow
something stopping him from doing it if
you think about people that could have
started a successful third party over
this recent number of years bernie's at
the top of the list oh absolutely and
many people's frustration with him is
that he didn't just keep walking um
that's not criticism it's just as as i
said frustration the question i think
people have for you is number one
whether you'll be able to garner enough
money to really
um make the difference that you'd like
to make
number two whether or not there will be
enough diversity you know what third
parties have done and that's part of the
problem even calling it a third party um
what they've done traditionally is that
they've just kind of
anointed a candidate
my hope for the forward party would be
that you'd have a lot of really good
people running including for president
so that you know a friend of mine was
saying the other day you know if the
forward party gets a lot of really good
people from diverse political places
running
their debate will be the more
interesting one that people will want to
watch in 2024 because that if the
president runs again i think it's
if there is even a debate at that point
but
people the democratic party has become
so yadda yadda i think of the republican
party as representing a nosedive for our
democracy and i think of the democratic
party as representing a managed decline
for our democracy and neither one of
them they represent such a solid status
quo it is not going to interrupt itself
this is going to take an intervention by
the american people i like the idea of
rejuvenation and i also love the idea of
having an independent nomination process
for the forward party uh where anyone
can participate and you can imagine
that primary being fascinating because
uh you'll have hundreds of people
running if not more well there'd be so
many people
too
that would realize that they'd get a
fair shake uh outside of the democratic
party or the republican party now it's
the republican party just a quick you
know
like
a synopsis of how that's going to go
down so
you'll have trump running um he'll be
running against uh generally some
second-tier types who feel they have no
choice but to run against trump and hope
something breaks their way um so it's
going to be mike pence maybe mike pompeo
chris christie nikki haley um i think
nikki haley nikki hell has already
publicly said she doesn't run against
trump um so she's uh taking herself out
if trump is there ron desantis has
privately said he will not run against
trump if trump is there um so that's one
reason i'm saying that either one of
those could be his vp candidate that's
part of it
and so they're also on the younger side
they're like yeah i'll sit out one cycle
and then just come back around whereas
if they go against trump then it could
be a career destroyer destroyer because
a lot of the base republican party could
turn on them in a lasting way
so that's one reason why trump's
opposition will likely be the
relatively
less strong candidates the strongest
candidate that seems poised to run
against him in my opinion is larry hogan
of maryland who's turned out no because
he would be more of the
yeah
young can yeah
let's say you were um an independent
human who wanted to run for president if
you tried to insert yourself into the
republican primary you're not going to
get a real shot given that trump will be
taking up all the oxygen there'll be
some other figures
[Music]
so let's say joe is running again i
think the democratic party will
try to
have joe run again because they don't
want it to go to a primary i don't i
don't agree with you i think that
in the scuttlebutt that
so what are you hearing i'm not sure
that everyone in the corporatist elite
would prefer that he run again
okay so he would have a very different
uh race against trump next time
i mean he only lost in many ways you
know a large factor involved in his
losing last time was covet and trump's
losing last time yeah and he won't be
able to claim that he's done much better
right so uh i agree that joe eked out a
win uh and would struggle to win again
and it sounds like people
are
seeing that so it sounds like the
democratic party is casting about for
the next person up it also sounds like
they're not enthusiastic about kamala um
kamala pulls five to six points worse
than joe
um so there has to be some kind of
elegant way to
go around
um the the natural
thing which would be to say well vice
president you know next next person up
um and so they
will want someone like peter amy yeah
peter amy who who they're on board with
yeah um now one of the interesting
things is that if it is that process
then you can't just anoint that person
because there has to be a primary
um so let's say there is a primary joe
doesn't run
kamala probably does not stand down she
probably runs unless they
i don't know what the heck they could
convey to her where it's like don't run
for president even though at this point
you would have been vice president for
several years so you're suggesting there
will be a democratic primary and it will
be kamala
pete amy and then figures tbd but at
that point then it's relatively open
and so you could wind up with
a whole set of figures and in that case
then there are debates for sure then
there are debates for sure the
elite corporatist element at top would
still try to suppress any progressive or
progressives
and then the question would be whether a
progressive who was able
to
mount
the argument you know to me it's not
about who to me it's about what and the
what is the articulation
of the political possibilities and the
political agenda that matches the deeper
yearning of the american people at this
time and the deeper needs particularly
of the working class it's the what to me
the question in my mind right now it's
not the who it's the what and then you
say well who who best to do it but it's
the what that what is that is what they
want to suppress
that what if done by the right person
with the right campaign
would garner the excitement of the
american people then the question is
when the dnc tries to suppress that
person will that person have the
gumption will that person have the
courage will that person have the power
to say oh i'm still running for
president i'm just not running with you
guys well they could just join the
forward party
if the forward party is still available
at that time well because the timing of
it would be that the um democratic
primaries get resolved well it's our
the forward party primaries would
probably be contemporaneous you're right
so you know would be whether
they can jump in if they've already yeah
but i was thinking about that the other
day because i i've
gone through some of these scenarios in
my head so i was saying to somebody the
other day if a person runs as a democrat
and then
does the scenario that we just said
which is to help with you you're you're
shutting me down but the american people
are lifting me up so i'm going to go
over there wouldn't a lot of the
activists
um grassroots people with the forward
party who've been there from the
beginning say oh right now you want us i
mean i could just see all that kind of
stuff well this is a pretty good
argument for not making it uh
contemporaneous and maybe just starting
the forward party primary a little later
there are many ways this could go uh
because the the calendar the political
calendar is made up
um so you have the
general elections in november the
um
presidential debates occur
typically pretty close up to that
date september october so the forward
party nominee just needs to be settled
uh you know sometime in the summer
really and that that's when the two
majors have their conventions so there
could be a fascinating forward party
convention in 24 that coal you just need
to decided who your person is um or you
could decide at the convention like old
school well do you think that you'll be
doing it
yeah
recently it's like
100 years ago with
guys chomping on cigars in the back room
deciding who they want i mean that's
what happened
um in 16 and in 20. let me ask you this
are you going to be doing primaries in
yeah in iowa and nevada and so the
argument for doing primaries in
um
the same states is that the press is
there it's a process people understand
like
there's
no
requirement uh you could do something
in different states you could do
multiple states at once you could you
know you can do a lot of different
things um the the
media angle would be that you decide to
follow the calendar because you figure
the reports are in reporters are in iowa
new hampshire anyway covering right you
know one of the other so then they they
could just be like while i'm here i
might as well see the the forward party
event you know i have said
many times and i
feel it strongly what i got from running
and i think this drives a little with
your book
a lot with your book the system was even
more corrupt than i knew but people were
even more wonderful than i hoped for
and i don't know about you i assume
you you feel the same way i was so
impressed by the voters in those primary
states
they took their role so seriously they
were so knowledgeable about
the issues
um they knew that their vote could
affect the world
they would kick the tires in a really
good way because it made you a better
candidate to always be asked about the
issues even though the press the press
was reporting on i mean it was two
different universes for me it was two
parallel universes there was the
exhilarating experience of being with
voters who really were down for serious
conversation about the um issues and
then
the press and it's
what it was doing two different worlds
with and so one was exhilarating one was
brutal but within the world of that
which was exhilarating i.e really
talking to voters it only made me
believe more strongly
in
the opportunities of democracy in the
possibility of a government of the
people by the people and for the people
and a greater commitment in my life to
do whatever it's beautiful so when you
say that the there was even more
corruption in the system than you uh
than you thought possible are you
referring to the media the democratic
party or both
well clearly in my case it was you know
after the second debate somebody clearly
said get her off the stage and within
three days you couldn't
pick up a
newspaper or
your computer or watch television that i
wasn't crazy and dangerous
and i
they knew that i was getting my sea legs
in the second one and by the third one i
think it would have been a major
inconvenience
the corruption of the system around
that uh i agree with you about like that
there's certainly like a media
relationship with the party where it's
like okay like that let's oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah they're they're in
lockstep and it's if if you are the
object
you know of that
decision to ridicule
you see how it works
i mean it's almost fascinating
boy
well you have to be a very strong person
to walk through that
yeah well you have to have a strategy of
walking through it and i didn't
well so one of the things i uh admire so
much about you is that you are a very
spiritual person like you know it's like
you're you're not someone who's
sense of self is second hand you've got
a much deeper relationship with both the
world and your own values it must have
been infuriating it was infuriating and
i also
took some advice that i regret taking
which is don't speak to it because that
will bring attention to it but if you're
running for president the attention is
on it and i wish that every time one of
those ridiculous articles was written
that i'd gotten on facebook live the
next day
to say what's really going on here
but i i also don't you know i don't want
to be a person with a chip on my
shoulder or anything like that i think
you know i'm 100 responsible for my
experience etc so i want to come at
everything i just said from a
descriptive place not from a resentful
place you know because no matter what
people do to you
the issue is who you are in the space of
what they do
and how do you transform that energy to
make it something wonderful now and i
think that that's what people what we
what we all love about you
forward
forward like you know let's
and especially now and also if you can't
rise above your own personal past
challenges how can you be a leader
in um
helping a country to emerge from its
past and that's that positivity you know
we need a blend of the positivity that
you represent and a very serious and
sober analysis of the problems that
confront us and my sense of the american
people voters talking to voters is that
people are smart you know i i have a
whole career decades um
very up close and personal
with people who just got bad news right
the test came back and it's cancer
your only choice is to go bankrupt
your spouse is leaving you and you
didn't even expect it
and what i have seen over and over and
over again is that sometimes when people
get the really bad news
that's when they become the most
intelligent
i've watched people who just received
the bad news from the doctor and in the
first five minutes so much unimportant
ultimately unimportant information and
and just stuff that fills your mind just
falls away and you get very serious and
that's not when you get stupid that's
when you say to the doctor
tell me tell me everything and tell me
what we need to do
and so sometimes it's when people are
as serious as we all need to be now you
know a lot of times politicians will say
don't tell people the bad news because
it will depress them which isn't has
infantilized the american public the
american public are seeing the bad news
now yeah yeah
and we need somebody who's not trying to
uh whitewash any of that pour pink paint
over it
be very clear about it so that we can
all be sober about it mature about it
courageous about it and talk with faith
and positivity about how we're going to
turn this thing around
[Music]
i love building the forward party
because it it's
natural for me uh no i'm an entrepreneur
and
um someone who is very comfortable with
the early stages of an organization than
seeing it grow is a joy it's a little
bit like being a parent you're a parent
but when you know when you see your
child start to do things you're like
yeah i've started organizations and
non-profits and it is like parenting uh
it is like parenting yeah yeah it's
lovely uh and the fact that so many
people are at least curious about the
forward party i mean the the test is for
us to execute and build up and
demonstrate that we can have a positive
role in various races in 22 and then
maybe sky's the limit in 24. so you just
uh projected forward
uh based upon some conversations and you
live in in dc right yeah um so based
upon some conversations that we may have
uh
an an open-ish democratic primary to
look forward to with kamala pete amy as
the three most conspicuous figures um
that are top of mind when you made that
list and i'm friends or friendly with
each of those people
from the presidential
i think that
trump would beat any of them absolutely
the barbie and kendall version of
politician is not going to beat donald
trump next time
i agree and unfortunately we live in a
world where like what i just said is
like a political statement where you
know you're not allowed to give your
opinion about like uh
you know like a particular contest and
someone will be like oh it's because you
this it's like i
just believe that
trump would uh would win that's my
backdrop for we're okay like you know we
probably should be thinking
differently or thinking a little bit
bigger if you imagine an openish
democratic primary
uh it seems that there really should be
some more people inserting themselves
into that race
i would think there would be if there's
an open if there's an open one and
the president is not running again i
would think that there you will have a
lot more democrats running wow it would
be but i would think that the elite will
still be putting their money uh
behind uh
um pete and amy although
they can't be that stupid to think that
the same old same old was going to beat
trump next time i don't know
yeah uh
it's one reason why i thought that they
would return to joe
though you're hearing different
um joe would be 82 and 24 so that that's
you know a factor i think um i know many
voters regarded joe as a bridge
candidate in 2020 but he told he said
publicly he saw himself as a bridge
candidate to pete buddhijet
he actually said that i see my job my
role he said is to create a space for
leadership
pete putih this leadership within the
democratic party
wow because i thought that when he
referred to himself as a bridge
candidate he was standing next to kamala
harris and cory booker um maybe them i'm
sure corey ran last time maybe he'll run
next time probably corey probably would
run again if that if it was open yeah if
it was open mm-hmm okay
so
that would be
fascinating and you're suggesting that
someone what's fascinating about it
cory's a lovely man i'm not this is not
personal but
it's very stale to me the whole
conversation not the people but the
conversation that we would be having
which would be
the the democrats do what they can to
address on the periphery the suffering
of tens of millions of people in this
country but they still refuse to address
the underlying forces mainly corporate
forces that make all that suffering
inevitable
and i don't think people are going to
buy it this time i think that anyone who
feels like the establishment would lose
to trump yeah i think the establishment
has not been having
uh let's say
glory days
sorry and i mean kovid kovitt has made a
lot of people question a lot of things
it's also made people
distressed
angry hostile
and in that environment
it's hard to be the establishment uh you
know and come and say hey you know
more of this like it's just a very
difficult case unless you are you know
look at the things that biden could be
doing even with you know everybody talks
about managing and cinema look at all
the things he could be doing just with
the power of the presidency he could be
declaring a national medical emergency
giving himself the power to expand
medicare to everyone he could be
canceling the college loan debt he could
be uh he he could be legalizing
marijuana he could be actively
supporting uh at least a 15 an hour
minimum wage even beyond federal workers
he could be actively supporting the pro
act
he could be you know there is so much
that the president could be doing to
make a stand for the rights of the
american people and the security of the
american people i think we have to
rethink money
i think we have to see money not just in
terms of
the
mechanistic data but in terms of what it
does to people not only economically but
emotionally and psychologically to live
at the effect of chronic economic trauma
people are like people cannot breathe
you and i know this you know we've both
had
the joy as well as the success of
entrepreneurial endeavors
we needed capital
we we were supported by capital we were
supported by education we were supported
by people who love us if we had been
stuck in these survival modes of having
to work every day and jobs that we hated
just in order to pay for college loans
that we had taken out in order to pursue
the career we really wanted but then
even when we got the education we
couldn't pursue the career we really
wanted because if we did that we
wouldn't have benefits like health care
so we have to continue working at these
terrible jobs in order to pay those
college loan debts and we're talking
about 44 million americans we're talking
about 40 million americans who even
before the pandemic could not absorb a
four or five hundred dollar unexpected
expenditure we're talking about tens of
millions of people who were in poverty
before the pandemic and millions more
who have dropped into it we're talking
about people who have no chance of a
decent education we're talking about
millions of americans who by the age of
10
have already
so far
dropped behind and i know that this is
something you tried to address as a
mayoral candidate in new york these kids
who have dropped so far behind by the
time they're 10 years old that they have
more of a chance of landing in prison
someday than of ever graduating from
high school
we we need to discuss these things these
are dark underbellies of the shadow
form of of of unfettered capitalism that
is now holding tens of millions of
people
in such in such survival and in such
trauma and what's going to happen is
that the person at the maga rally and
the person at the union protest are
going to start looking at each other and
going you know what we're being
suppressed by the same forces we're
being oppressed by the same forces the
exploitation of the worker the
exploitation of the average american in
service to this monarchical neo-monarchy
neo our um aristocratic system that to
me is the conversation that matters and
i you know we make it about the horse
race but
i think if those two
workers were to look at each other and
say hey we're we're getting uh screwed
by the same people on the same forces
they wind up in the forward party they
would but how that i i would
agree with you given
given the way the democratic party is
now constituted that the institutional
resistance to really standing for the
working people of america is so great
within the democratic party going
straight to the forward party carries
the questions the challenges that you
know very well
um and i i think you know i don't i
think i'm one of millions of people in
the united states who really hope you're
going to be able to pull this off well
thank you marianne but that's not to say
you know that's not you know we don't
everybody's like oh how a third party is
is perceived but i think we're looking
very closely i i think that millions
obviously it's intrigue it's curiosity
you know yeah yeah yeah and if we
execute well
yes yes yes yes completely i i'm so
excited about it um so one you're right
that there is something
uh
of a distraction element if you look at
the horse race uh i think you're a
characterization of the parties as nose
dive republican party magic client
democratic party and the democratic
party is almost constitutionally
wired to make it the party of managed
decline like it's going to be very hard
for it to become like because of the
suppression of the real progressive
candidates because of the corporate uh
control
of much of it and that the candidates
that
that end up in office a very very
limited appetite for like the big
wholesale sweeping changes it's so
ironic because the republican party
stands for the more elitist policies but
they have an ironically more egalitarian
relationship to their own constituency
the democrats stand for more egalitarian
policies but ironically a more elitist
relationship to their own constituency
oh yeah like you have to audition to get
in oh yeah if the people get behind
someone they're like no no that's not
what you want that's not fun yeah i know
the republican party
for
they have massive massive problems they
don't even have a policy platform last i
checked but
they let the voters decide and if the
voters decided on a crazy person they're
like well guess crazy person uh you know
well some of them are not happy with how
that turned out
you know their own
divide is as interesting as the
democratic party divide yeah the the
republican party and this is one reason
why
in my view we have to break up the
duopoly as quickly as possible is you
have a lot of i'm sure very sane
republicans looking up being like well
you know like don't like what's going on
but if i want to keep my job keep my
career in some cases avoid death threats
you know like i'll just keep my head
down and go along with this i'm friendly
with some of the republican members of
congress who made the decision to
impeach trump their lives got turned
upside down and then they threatened in
some cases yeah threatened
more than
when i say upside down i mean they had
to go into hiding they're like threats
against them and their family the whole
thing and then they had colleagues who
saw the same thing playing out or like
pass
you know and then and you look at then
you say can you blame them
you know like i think we should truly be
elevating
uh the adam kinsingers and the peter
meyers and like the brave souls who
decided look like i think it's the right
thing to do they have not been properly
uh protected or
recognized
in my opinion well i do wonder sometimes
what's going on behind the scenes in
terms of police protection of some of
these obviously at-risk lawmakers but at
this point it's not just lawmakers who
are threatened just election officials
on state level people who count the
votes now we have very a very
um
a serious problem with fringe elements
who represent
genuine nazi and fascist elements but
this was all made possible because we
haven't been harnessing the real dignity
and decency and intelligence of the
american people because neither the
democrats nor the republicans
really saw their power lying and doing
so
[Music]
i agree with your characterization of
nosedive manage decline and then you
know need something
uh new or different approach but people
sometimes ask me it's like oh do you
think that you know like do you think
the democratic party's issues are the
same or equivalent to the republican
party's issues this is something where
the the democrats get very
upset where if you say hey you guys have
problems be like oh but our problems are
not nearly as bad as as the other sides
and then and i i would say though i
never have this conversation because you
know they're not interested in the
conversation but
but it's that look i don't think your
problems are the same as the republican
parties they're very different like
these problems are asymmetrical but you
do have problems it's a very immature
level of conversation it's like if i was
you know when i counseled people and
they will say well ninety percent of it
is their problem and i'll say well we
have to address the ten percent of it
that's yours it's very infantile the way
we can't talk about our problems we're
only going to talk about the other guy's
problems on a level of personal growth
that's
so immature and unevolved and on the
level of organizational growth or
systems growth it's also infantile and
unevolved and
the democratic party as long as you
can't in any way criticize the
democratic party you're seen as an enemy
of the democratic party if you criticize
the democratic party like you're saying
then number one the democratic party
will not change the democratic party
will lose to the trumps and the
neo-trumps and more and more americans
will feel politically homeless
if if there was a straight line to you
you'd say well okay that's simple enough
but it's what i just said doesn't make
the path simple and that's why once
again and i mean it um i mean it when i
say this
[Music]
how you
guide this ship
it's going to be really important and i
really wish you well well thank you mary
ann we're going to do our best i
have a sense of urgency because i think
the next three years are going to be
crucial
uh talking to you is uplifting because i
sense that you're going to have a role
to play in 24 which is very exciting
this
image of a democratic primary
leading into 24
is interesting to me because i will say
like i didn't think there was going to
be a genuine primary i thought they'd
just be like look clear the decks give
it uh
but they can't clear the decks for
anyone that's not joe
so you're going to have a genuine
process
which does raise some opportunities for
let's say a marion williamson or someone
else to to run
um to the extent that i'm focused on 24
it is around a third party primary which
i think would be so fun and
invigorating and fascinating and
genuinely open and possibly more
interesting we'll see
and possibly a lot more interesting i
mean you're gonna have trump wrecking
people on one side
like dems you know i i suppose duking it
out but you'll be like yeah you know you
know it's gonna be like yeah like it's
gonna be one of like a
couple of candidates and you know that
they're going to be uh
more of the same in some fundamental
ways and and i think this appetite for
change the american people have been
um
you know manifesting or you know like
signaling they want i think if you had
so i'm i'm the numbers guy the math guy
um so the things i i describe to people
look ross pro got 19.3 percent of the
vote as a third party candidate in
you really are the math guy which was a
more trusting not everybody walks around
knowing what percentage of the vote uh
ross program
oh yeah sure and by the way
ross perot suspended his campaign
briefly before unsuspecting i remember
that so if he'd just go on the whole way
he gets higher than 19.3 but let's just
say let's just take 19.3
um then you have uh
mark cuban in 2020 who pulled himself at
25
wow 44 of americans describe themselves
as as independents 62 percent want to
move on from the duopoly
if you have trump and let's say
uh you know pete or amy or kamala
i think that a strong independent or
third-party candidate walks around with
15 to 20
pretty straightforwardly if they have
the resources and can't message out and
you know people though in this day of uh
independent media i think it would you
this person would get energy because
there would be a lot of americans are
looking up saying like i'm really not
that excited about these two options
um if it were joe which was my original
projection um over 50 of americans don't
want joe to run again over 50 percent of
americans don't want trump to run again
so you'd have like this massive group of
americans looking for a real choice and
so if you presented them a choice they
thought was competitive and credible and
had
good people around them um i think they
start out in the 15 to 20 range maybe
higher um and then can they go from
20 to 25 28 30
if it's the right person i think so i i
think there are
a ton of americans who just wanted to
like
uh just want to try and reset the system
and it's going to be almost impossible
for
one of the
establishment dems to be like you know
who's going to reset the system me
because you know i've got a slightly
different identity than the last person
who built it you know it's just a really
weak case
i think a lot has changed in the last
year and a lot more will change over the
next year
my friend said the other day
people thought trump was the wake-up
call as it turns out
biden was the wake-up call
the wake-up call to the fact that
certain things don't change no matter
who is in power this stuff started this
massive transfer of wealth and
opportunity started with a republican
president no democratic president has
stopped it
the duopoly
represents that massive transfer even
though one yes is much worse than the
other it reminds me of the 12 steps of
alcoholics anonymous you know you start
by saying oh i can manage it and we've
been saying for years can the
republicans manage to
manage the problem can the democrats
manage the problem can the republicans
manage the problem can the democrats and
people are finally saying it can't be
managed it's unmanageable
the system itself has got to be
interrupted on such on such a on such a
level there must be an intervention and
the question and this is where
leadership comes in
um there is going to be you know i i
feel in 16
um
there was such a populist cry of despair
and it was going to express itself it
was either going to express itself to a
progressive populist like bernie
or a an authoritarian populist by like
um
like trump and as you have pointed out
as many have pointed out the dnc
kept the progressive populace from being
able to carry the banner that's why i
think he would have won in 2016. i think
you were won at this point we have
reached the stage already we're on an
emotional and psychological level we are
already in a civil war condition and
people need to read up about the french
revolution people need to read up about
the revolutions in the world over the
last um couple of centuries and if they
do
they realize that the masses are closer
to the gates of the best deal than they
might think
there is going to be
there's going to be a revolution the
question is it going to be a peaceful
revolution or violent revolution jfk
said those who make a peaceful
revolution impossible make a violent
revolution inevitable
so those who are trying to suppress the
genuine progressive populist fervor
within the democratic party
are obstructing the path of a peaceful
revolution
and that to me is the question
we need
guides that's what the political leader
today should be we're going to make
these changes because we've got to make
drastic economic changes we've got to
like fdr said people will not stand by
while the things that they should be
given are being denied to them year
after year after year
they will not stand by
we must make even if as fdr said through
drastic measures
we must right this ship where a certain
kind of crony unfettered unregulated
capitalism now acts like a constant
suppressant
suppressant on the health and the
well-being and the safety and security
of the average american and we need to
guide that change the change will happen
either it will explode in very violent
ways or it will come about through wise
leadership and we need to develop not
only the constituency which i think is
already there to be harnessed but
the leadership
um and hopefully you and i and what and
other people in whatever ways
we can will be part of that
uh well i pledge to you that if you do
run uh in the forward party process
we'll be much nicer to you than than the
dnc was
nice to me i remember the day you and i
met here in new york city
um
i love you a lot of people do oh thank
you marianne i love you too i want to
follow up on what you just suggested
about either the violent revolution or
the peaceful revolution i made a similar
case in 2020 when i was running i was
like hey guys like we have to get our
acts together or else like you know like
it's going to uh it's going to get ugly
it's going to get nasty
um i'm going i'm going to say something
maybe rough but i think we're past that
point um i think it's going to get rough
and nasty and violent
uh and it's probably happening in this
next cycle in in 24
i wish i felt differently but it's just
you know it happens to be the way i feel
i think we're getting set up for this
um the when you say we already have
these conditions agree
um you know where you talked about the
damage that the country had undergone
back when you and i were running for
president and that was before covet and
the rest of it like now we've gotten
just completely a lot's changed it's
gotten it's gotten worse and at the same
time largely because it's gotten worse
there's been more of an awakening and
you see some positive signs too look at
the emergence of the labor the labor
movement this year i mean it's it's
extraordinary what's happening starbucks
kellogg nabisco john deere
amazon some really good things are
happening people are waking up certainly
more and more people are continuing to
awaken about the
within the environmental movement the
problem is the government does not
respond to the awakening of the people i
know when bernie was out i think it was
at the kellogg with the keller workers
and he wrote he read a letter from biden
and biden said
keep the faith
biden should have been out there on the
street with those striking workers keep
the faith you're the president do
something we're in an age now marianne
where it's like hey if i make the
appropriate statement or gesture then
that is my job it's performative yeah
yeah and um that there are a number of
americans are just totally sick of it so
one thing i wanted to follow up on too
on this is that when you look at the
presentation of like hey
get let's get our [ __ ] together or else
there will be civil war
um you know who agrees with that a lot
of conservatives
in large part because a lot of
conservatives for better for worse have
this framing of like you know that
there's like the oppression and we have
to rise against the oppressors and the
media is part of the oppressors and like
all the stuff it's like you know
and if you say hey civil war folks on on
certainly in the establishment would be
like don't be alarmist uh you know
except the alarms are already on yeah
they're telling us not to be alarmist
but the alarms are already ringing yeah
at this point now it now that there is
this waking up you're describing where
if you say hey we're going to degenerate
into civil war strike violence etc now
people who are in the establishment and
people who are you know democrats and
whatnot will look at it now and say like
yeah yeah that's a real concern in a way
before that they would not and one of
the reasons i think that they didn't
want to talk about it is because there's
this sense that well if i talk about it
then it becomes more likely to happen
it's magical thinking it's ridiculous
and you know people would say you're
being negative and i've always said you
know if the house is burning yelling
fire it's not negative yeah
yeah and also once again going back to
you know i've worked so much up and
close and personal with people in
trouble when you're in trouble you have
to talk about it you can't deny it
you have to
you have to talk about it you have to
process it
so before the the camera started rolling
um you and i talked a little bit about
like these two paths these two projects
which is one make the changes from
within the democratic party number two
start a new party and give rise to this
new popular movement
and the relative chances of each of them
working
um and then how we would have our best
use
uh like and people ask me all the time
hey you're gonna run for president and i
honestly say you know like i'll do
whatever i think will be most useful
uh so what do you see
ahead for you over this next
several years uh um you could say the
same thing i said which is like i'll do
whatever i think the most useful thing
is
um
certainly i'd love to enlist you for
this project like the you know well i do
feel what you feel i do feel i want to
do
whatever
would serve best i think each of us you
seek to find what role would be best for
me that i would be the greatest use and
least in the way some people would say
go away that would be the way you'd be
at least i'm not going away but where i
do go
i know very smart people
who are having this conversation
i know very smart people i know many of
you your people watching right now and
listening
are sitting with this question in their
heart
and i think and i said this earlier in
the program i think that this year for
myself and for many of us
answers will be getting more clearer
someone said something to me the other
day that blew my mind marianne but it
was a true fact they said early 2019 was
three years ago
really it's so extraordinary how much
has happened and i think a lot's going
to happen this coming year
it's going to be a big year and
i know you're going to be a huge part of
it marianne
not the last time you and i sit down
together or break bread together uh
thank you so much for being here thank
you thank you for everything
[Music]
you